okay so welcome everyone the quantum
computers are coming
my name is Alistair Collinson I'm a
senior software developer for Zendikar
technology and blah blah blah you don't
really care about any of that do you
there's one thing really that you have
to know about me I'm a nerd I'm a huge
nerd in fact I'm so much of a nerd that
my colleagues call me a nerd and they're
you know other computer scientists and
mathematicians and physicists now
personally I'm not a physicist not at
all
last time I had any formal education in
physics is ages ago but I am here
nevertheless to speak about quantum
computers and the good news is you don't
have to be a physicist anymore to get
into quantum computing it's the time now
where being a nerd is sufficient and
that's really good news because in
looking at you here you're probably not
going to need quantum computers for your
job yet you're sitting here watching a
talk on quantum computers
chances are you two are nerds okay so
what is a quantum computer let's get
started with a very basic term and the
easier part of that is what is a
computer well this is a computer rather
older than what you probably use I hope
this one could argue is the first
computer ever at least the first
electronic digital programmable computer
that Souza's eight three and digital or
binary is a big point there when we
think of binary we normally think of
zeros and ones but that's not really
true is it we don't have zeros and ones
in our computers we have two distinct
States and four we care about it could
be a green circle in the red triangle as
long as they are distinct that's fine
now computers nowadays work with
transistors
well smaller than those more like the
here built into small trips and the way
that transistors work is basically that
depending on their input they either let
a current go through or they don't two
distinct states wonderful and this is
great
for loads and loads of problems I mean
the fact that we are where we are with
computing technology nowadays is due to
the fact that this is such a versatile
versatile tool but it's not great for
everything and I'm going to show you an
example of something it's not great at
as nerds you may be not that familiar
with this but nature ok so nature is not
binary let's have a look at a close part
of that and try to try to determine
where we have forests so this part
that's clearly forest this part clearly
isn't forest but what about that part I
mean you clearly have some trees there
right but most of it is grass so where
do we draw the line when do we call it a
forest and that question where do we
draw the line we have to draw an
arbitrary line we have to decide how
much say trees per square kilometer or
whatever counts as a forest and when we
have to draw such a line when we have to
make a decision
we are artificially making our world
binary binary problems are great for
computers non-binary problems not so
much okay so that's the computer part I
think we're all up to speed now the
quantum part so quantum as you may have
guessed is based on quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics was first introduced
by Niels Bohr and Karl Avila Kyle
Heisenberg they worked together in the
1920s came up with quantum mechanics and
what they called the
the Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics named after the city where
they work together now I am NOT going to
explain all of quantum mechanics partly
because as I said I'm not a physicist
and partly because even if I were we
would need more than the time we have
available so I'll give you an example
and the example is imagine we have an
atom in fact we don't care about the
whole atom all we care about is the
nucleus here and let's say that our atom
is radioactive
what does radioactivity mean it means
basically that at some point it will
decay which means that part of it will
radiate away this radioactive particle
and alpha particle in this case will
leave the nucleus and what remains will
be some other element so assuming we
have our particle our atom and we wait
for a certain time if we look at that
particle there are two states we could
imagine it being in I thought it hasn't
changed at all or it has decayed right
according to the Copenhagen
interpretation of quantum mechanics it
can be both at the same time that is it
can be both at the same time until we
actually measure it now don't be
confused by those eyes I'm not stating
that there's any connection between
consciousness and physics looking is one
way of measuring it but anything that
relies on its being in one State or the
other accounts so nevertheless this is a
really really weird thing to imagine how
can something be in two states at the
same time and so Schrodinger here in
1935 he thought there was this was
pretty weird so he came up with a
thought experiment showing how
absolutely weird the the interpretation
was that Heisenberg and Bohr had come up
with
in this experiments which you may have
heard of he has a cat and this cat is
totally fine it's healthy it's not
likely to die within the next hour of so
of natural causes and he puts this cat
into a box the cats however is not the
only thing in the box what else do we
have
well we have a radioactive source of
some kind this is very similar to the
radioactive atom we had previously it's
just more of them and this source has
been chosen in a particular way so that
if one hour passes the chance that any
of it has decayed is 50/50 okay what
else do we have well there's also a
flask filled with cyanide gas in there
cyanide gas of course highly poisonous
it's better if the gas stays in that
flask but he added a 1/4 thing he added
a construction which consists of a
Geiger counter that if it measures any
radioactivity
we'll use that hammer and what will
happen there well dead cat so if we
again imagine an hour passes what are
the states that we could have well I
thought the radioactive isotope has not
done anything it's not decayed in any
way and the case is fine or well the
cat's dead two possible States and
according to the Copenhagen
interpretation we could have both of
them together we could have them at the
same time I mean how can cat be dead and
alive at the same time right
Schrodinger wasn't thinking of zombie
cats as far as I can tell but it's
definitely a weird concept and so he
came up with an alternative
interpretation because he did believe
that the maths behind quantum mechanics
was correct he just thought that the
Copenhagen interpretation was nonsense
and the interpretation he came up with
is called the many-worlds interpretation
now before I get into what the
many-worlds interpretation means I have
a small disclaimer for us for our
purposes the many-worlds interpretation
is a model it helps us understand
certain aspects of the topic it's really
good at that if it's chosen well but
models have something else often models
are wrong in many ways and that's fine
as long as they're wrong in ways that we
don't care about and the many-worlds
interpretation for our purposes is right
in where it counts it may or may not be
correct in all of all I don't know I'm
not a physicist and I think even
physicists are unsure about this
it certainly writes in the ways we care
about okay with that just came out of
the way what does the many-worlds
interpretation say well it says first of
all take everything that is the world
the galaxy the universe it couldn't find
a picture of the universe but the
galaxies here will work and in this
universe among other things you have
your cat now when this radioactive event
happens this quantum event so to speak
you don't get your zombie cat situation
rather what happens is that you get two
universes and basically they're carbon
copies of each other with one exception
and that exception is the result of your
quantum event and everything that
followed from that so in one universe
you
have a live cat in one universe you have
a dead cat and of course this can happen
again if you have another radioactive
event quantum event giving you four
universes and again giving you eight
universes you get the picture now one
thing you may notice on this slide is we
have rather many dead cats and well
that's not that Pleasant thing is we
have this situation because of biology
in our universe at least and probably in
all other relevant universes if you have
a dead cat and add more cyanide you
don't get a live cat that's not how
biology works or chemistry or anything
luckily for us cats and quantum
computers are different in that aspect
so now we're getting to the actual meat
of the matter what we see here is called
a Blas fear and it's a represent
representation of a qubit a quantum bit
that's the equivalent of your zeros and
ones your bits or your there is a
current and there's no current your
green circle and your red triangle this
is the equivalent in the quantum
computing world so what states can we
have in there well first of all you can
have a zero state which is represented
by your vector pointing to the top there
you can have a one state which is
represented by pointing to the bottom so
that's simple enough but you can also
have something that looks like this now
this isn't zero and it isn't one it's
not really between the two either at
least not in this visualization it's
somewhere on the sphere and
mathematically speaking this is actually
a combination of the two base values
we're using now if that math confuses
you because I mean zero at the bottom
at the top ones at the bottom how can
some of that be somewhere else
ignore the math we don't need it for the
rest of the talk it is a combination it
makes sense in the mathematical model
the Bloch sphere is a three-dimensional
representation of four-dimensional space
it gets mathematical we don't have to
care about it what we have to care about
is okay assuming we have this qubit what
can we do with it and if you want to do
something with a qubit you need a
quantum gate so let's go through a few
quantum gates first one I want to show
you is the so called Hadamard gate so
the Hadamard gate operates on a single
qubit and basically it imagines that
there's a further axis between the x and
the z axis and it then spins our vector
around that axis now if you are
measuring a qubit if it's at the zero
position it will give you zero all of
the time binary value if it's a 1 it
will give you 1 all of the time if it's
somewhere in between it will give you 0
and 1 with certain probabilities so if
we were to measure measure it's at this
point in an ideal quantum computer at
least you would get 0 and 1 each with
50% probability this state where you can
have 0 or 1 as a readout is called
quantum superposition and we'll need
that very soon another gate I'll gonna
I'm gonna show you is called the power
Li X gates now the X gate is much much
simpler to understand than the the
Hadamard gate because basically if you
have it at 0 and deploy an X gate it
just takes the x axis and spins it
around there by a hundred and eighty
degrees giving you the opposite value so
this is basically just a knot around the
X X
is not is easy enough to understand
right but it gets more complicated if
you go to another gate which
incorporates part of what you know from
the ex gate now so the conditional not
or C not gate is where things get really
exciting and basically this operates on
two qubits we have the the control qubit
at zero here and we have the target
qubit and if we apply a C not with the
control qubit at zero nothing happens
everything stays the same if we have a
one on the control qubit and apply the C
not it will flip so basically this is
the behavior we know from the ex gate
but what happens if our control Q gate
is in superposition if it could be
measured as 0 or 1 we get something like
this so we now have two arrows in that
second qubit basically it's a bit like
this because if you were to measure
either of the gates you would get the
value of both gates they are combined
they are locked together if you have 0
in the first one you'll get 0 in the
second one because nothing happens if
you get one in the first one you'll get
one in the second one because everything
happens this is the situation we had
with our radioactive isotope and our cat
earlier this is quantum entanglement and
quantum entanglement combines with
quantum superposition is what makes
quantum computers and quantum mechanics
in general tick now we don't actually
have this until we measure before we
measure we basically just have both in
superposition
and as long as they're in superposition
we can do some really funky stuff with
these qubits now I've shown you a few
quantum gates namely the Hadamard and
the C not gates I've shown you one of
the three pearly gates there are y&z
pearly gates as well they just spin
around their axes by 180 degrees those
axis just being wild said there's also
stuff like the identity gate which is
the most boring gates ever because it
just does nothing there are phase gates
which are pretty exciting you can do
some pretty neat stuff with those I'm
not going to get into the phase gates
today but you can read up on them if you
like I'll have some material some links
for you later
and there are many many other types of
gates you can imagine so okay we now
know roughly how it works but why do we
need this what are the use cases and
there are quite a few use cases actually
for example the big one that if you've
heard anything about quantum computing
you've heard about this it can break
encryption and it can break encryption
because at least in theory it can break
it because it's really good at prime
factorization quantum computers can
factorize numbers much more efficiently
in theory at least then your regular
binary computers can do it if you want
to know more about that check out Shor's
algorithm something you may not have
heard of various companies including
Google and Fox wagon are using quantum
computers now to assist them in
engineering tasks you could simulate
molecules and atoms on quantum computers
you actually have a quantum states there
so you can easily work with quantum
at ease and this can be really useful in
research in physics and chemistry and
medicine of course so this could be
really really exciting
other than that how about AI or machine
learning there are quite a few attempts
to use quantum computers in those areas
and I think it's pretty safe to say that
those will be some of the first fields
that will we as developers will really
meet quantum computers at least in the
wild then you can use it for weather
prediction you can use quantum computers
for pretty much any fields that is
nowadays aided by heuristics because
heuristics are just a shortcut because
you aren't unable to calculate
everything but quantum computers will
allow you to calculate well not
everything but much much more then you
can nowadays financial fraud is another
use case that some people are looking
into again a field where heuristics is
large NASA is using quantum computers
early quantum computers and MIT Utley in
their engineering tasks so that's
similar to the Volkswagen case and just
to jump on the bandwagon quantum
computers could break Bitcoin so if you
have bitcoins you'll probably save for a
couple of years until we have quantum
computers that are powerful enough but
don't wait too long
to sell them ok so these are interesting
use cases I guess but there's much more
that could be done now most people who
nowadays are into quantum computers are
scientists physicists as I said
engineers etc and they come up with
solutions to the problems they know we
are the ones who will have to program
them eventually so we need people
who
in the programming field who are in the
software development field to have a
look at quantum computers try them out
work with them see what they can do we
will come up with other use cases use
cases that so far nobody has thought of
and this is basically why I'm doing this
talk today because we have to get into
quantum computing and we can so that's
why we as a community should get into it
why should you personally get into it
well there's this wonderful quote from
Venkat basically if you want to learn
something new learn something that's
totally different from anything you know
because it will help you think
differently it's a wonderful quote and
believe me quantum computer programming
is different from what you know so I'm
going to show you two examples today of
how you can actually today start
programming for quantum computers the
first one I'm going to show you is the
IBM quantum experience so iBM has built
real quantum computers early prototypes
but they are real nevertheless and
they're basically offering them as a
kind of quantum computer in the cloud
service how does that work well first of
all the computers they built look
something like this and if for the
moment yes I hope they'll shrink
considerably actually this part here
most of that is a freezer but a cryostat
but basically a huge freezer the chip
itself looks something like this this is
a seven qubit chip those are the qubits
here and it has to be cooled down to
well basically as cold as it can get
because they are based on super
conductivity and super conductivity well
it works best if you have really really
cold states now you can use this quantum
computer well
that specific one but once that they're
providing via their website this is the
entry sites to the quantum experience
they have great learning materials there
by the way so if you're interested in
this later you can check it out it's
great
once you log in what the place you'll
spend most of your time probably is this
this is called the quantum composer and
up here we have information about the
quantum computers that you can use they
currently offer for free by the way two
different five cubits computers but
anyone can use they also have in their
quantum experience in theory a twenty
cubed quantum computer that's only open
to their partners and it gives you some
information about those computers now
think it's difficult to read but the top
quantum computer it's cooled down to
0.01 to kelvins that's colder than out
of space that's why they have this huge
cryostat that's huge freezer and as
you'll see very soon that's still not
really enough so the main parts however
is this part the composer interface and
it's named so because it looks like you
know a musical score and you do call the
programs often quantum scores also you
have here your cue gates now you'll
recognize some of them there are the h4
Hadamard there's the the plus symbol
that's the C not you see the green X
that's the X gate and there are some
other ones as well so let's say we want
to implement an algorithm in this and
we'll go with something we already know
Schrodinger's cat very simple algorithm
to implement not much logic logic in it
but it's a start
so what do we need apart from the cat
well we need our radioactive matter we
need our modified Geiger counter
we need our cyanide and all of those
have to be linked in some way they have
to be entangled and if we lay that out
in our quantum composure it would look
something like this
so the radioactive matter we already
learned that is in quantum superposition
so we can achieve that through the
Hadamard gate we then link all of the
other items so the the Geiger counter
and the cyanide and the cat through C
not gates because basically if if the
Hadamard reads out as one that means
that the radioactive matter has decayed
and in that case all the other qubits
should also flip they all start out as
zero and if the first one flips
everything should turn to one and
looking into the box is basically this
pink symbol here the measurement gate in
fact let's measure all of the gates we
are modifying here and see what we get
now you can run this as I said on a real
quantum computer it's sent to their
quantum computer there's a scheduled
system etc and after a while you get
back your result and your results well
part of the result will look like this
so what does this mean at the bottom we
have the various measurement values
ignore the first value because that's
the qubit we didn't measure and what we
see is here this is the case where
everything's zero nothing happened so
that's a big peak back here we have the
case where everything happened
everything's a wand cat's dead and each
of those two results come to about 30% I
think I ran this test a thousand times
and you get 30% each which leaves 40% of
these results so what are those well
those are measurement errors
see this is still an early prototype and
it makes mistakes and quantum error
correction is actually a huge research
fields right now things are getting
better but you do have to keep in mind
that you can't believe all of the
results at the moment that you're
getting there is some randomness in
there basically due to the fact among
other things at least that it's not at
Absolute Zero it is those you know 21
millions above zero which isn't much but
it's still a bit too warm so that's the
quantum experience the other tool I
would like to show you today is the
Microsoft quantum development kit now
this the IBM quantum experience is
basically a drag-and-drop editor you can
write regular code as well they have a
programming language and it translates
back and forth between the graphical
interface and that language in most
cases at least for learning purposes you
will probably use the graphical
interface the quantum development kids
by Microsoft comes with a language
called cue sharp this looks much more
like in the code we're used to and as I
said it's from Microsoft so initially it
was only available for Windows and I
thought during the preparations for this
presentation I'd have to tell you well
if you have anything but windows tough
luck but about a month ago they said hey
it's now available for linux and mac OS
as well so everyone can download it
everyone can start playing around with
it yes ok so you can do it let's have a
look at what it looks like if you
actually do do it so the language cue
shop is heavily inspired by of Anette
languages as you would assume and it
does actually run inside a dotnet
environment
here we have a very simple program most
of its blurred out at the moment it's
not something about your eyes it really
should look like that and we'll go
through the program step by step so what
do we have first of all here we are
applying a Hadamard gate to our isotope
H isotope and then we apply the C not to
the isotope and the Geiger counter and
another C not to the Geiger counter and
the cyanide another C not to the cyanide
and the cat you know this and it's just
written down as code it's the same
algorithm as we did before what else do
we have because there's obviously more
code well first of all we define a
mutable value what we would call a
variable in most languages most things
in Q sharp are immutable
by default we want this to be mutable
and this variable is supposed to
represent the state of the cat is it
alive or is it dead this is a simple one
it's not a qubit value this is a binary
value here we check in the box whether
the cat is alive or dead M is the
measurement value this is the pink thing
you saw in the quantum experience same
concept and then at the end we return
you know is the cat alive or is it dead
okay simple enough what else do we have
we have boilerplate basically so here we
say this algorithm needs for qubits we
have to state explicitly how many we
need they will be provided by the
language then we give them proper names
normally you have an array of qubits and
that's fine initially but you can't
throw best practices out of the window
just because we have a new language is
language here we do have to give the the
qubits name so we can understand what
we're doing
then we initialize them all to zero the
quantum experience did this for us
everything was initially set to zero
cue sharp does not do this for us we
have to do it manually and at the end
we're setting them back to zero now the
reason we have to set them to zero
initially and at the end is basically
decay quantum decay means that a qubits
will always strive to some kind of
equilibrium state we want to make sure
it's not in equilibrium but rather it's
in a defined States that we can work
with and you could leave out
language-wise
the initializing to zero then we could
just get random results q shop forces
you actually to set them back to zero
when you're finished and that's
basically all of the Q sharp code now
this runs in the dotnet environment
which means we can access it from other
doughnut languages and so here we have a
few lines of c-sharp code which
basically say what here creates a
quantum simulator to run my algorithm in
run the algorithm in that quantum
simulator and then tell me what the
result is and you can run this code on
your computer it runs it just this once
in this case and it'll either tell you
the cat's alive or the cat is dead and
that's it this will run on your computer
so we have quantum simulator here and
that may beg the question then why don't
we just simulate it white do we need a
real quantum computer it obviously works
so why don't we just simulate everything
and don't have those measurement errors
that have the hassle it's a huge
financial investment that
companies like IBM for example and many
universities are taking on why do they
care and I'd like to go back to a
previous slide to answer that question
remember this slide now in theory the
slide is designed in such a way that
when I press my button here it will have
a smooth transition from the dead cats
to gravestones I clicked that wasn't
smooth my computer is having
difficulties with PowerPoint and what
stress would a quantum computer put on a
binary computer
well IBM actually looked into this issue
and they published a paper last year
they had two quantum computers that they
simulated one of them was a 49 qubit
computer and they needed to fund a half
terabyte of RAM one of them was a 56
qubit computer and that needed three
terabytes of RAM
note that this wasn't the same algorithm
and maybe the algorithm they used for
the latter was more optimized it's still
much more than we have on our
development machines there are computers
with that kind of memory available of
course but you don't have them sitting
at home I would assume if you do let me
know I might come by so this was a huge
success and you'll see why it was a huge
success with this line here previously
those kind of simulations would have
needed eight petabytes of RAM for the 49
qubits machine and an exabyte of RAM for
the 56 qubit machine let me repeat that
one exabytes of ram can you imagine how
much an exabyte is probably not so let
me break this down for you
one exabytes is a thousand petabytes
which is a million gigabytes terabytes
re which depending on whether you speak
British or American English is a mill
yard or a billion gigabytes that's ten
to the 18 bytes of RAM so intensive hits
CD 18 bytes that's hard to imagine our
universe according to current estimates
is thirteen point seven times ten to the
nine years old
that translates to four point three two
times ten to the seventeen seconds
that's less than half the amount of
bytes we have in an exabyte so the
improvement that IBM made thereby
getting it down to the terabyte range is
astonishing but as the number of qubits
grows that you have to emulate or
simulate and as the algorithms grow that
you want to simulate on those
simulations of quantum computers things
will get well even more unrealistic than
they are right now so at least for the
time being we are stuck with actual
physical quantum computers now this here
is a 50 cubits quantum computer that's
IBM built and until recently I thought
this would be the largest machine I'd be
able to show you about two weeks ago
Google came along and said hey we have
this thing here we call its Bristlecone
and it has 72 qubits and apparently very
low error rates now when they announced
it the testing wasn't fully completed so
we can't be absolutely sure what the
error rates look like but it's promising
note the the 50 qubit machine I showed
you I think that was from earlier this
year this is from two weeks ago things
are moving really rapidly and IBM and
Google aren't the only companies in the
game here for example intel is also
working on quantum computers at the
beginning of the year they introduced a
49 qubits
quantum computer after some previous
iterations the largest one in the
picture is the 49 qubit one and Alibaba
the Chinese Internet giant's announced
in early March that they were offering a
quantum computer in the cloud similar to
what IBM is offering now as I said
earlier IBM to certain partners offers a
20 qubit computer this here offered by
Alibaba is an 11 qubit computer which is
the second largest one available at
least it's available to some people I
registered with Alibaba looked for
anything and I could only find this
announcement so apparently it is
available in theory but only two were
probably members of the university with
which they are doing this or a research
institution I should say but things are
gonna happen quantum computers will
become more and more available in the
next months and especially years and so
this is the breaking point this is the
point where people like us have to get
started and can get started with quantum
computing so if you want to get started
what can you do well as I said earlier
there's the quantum experience you can
register there it's all free and they
have great learning material here's the
URL I will make the slides available
online so you don't have to remember
that URL right now great great tool for
learning there is as I said the IBA
there are Microsoft quantum development
kits available for it yeah sure sure
I'll still speak about the next slide
there's the Microsoft quantum
development kit available for Windows
Mac and Linux
this also is absolutely free of charge
and available under this URL
if you want to take pictures now would
be the time and also about one and a
half weeks ago Stack Exchange who run
this tiny less I called Stack Overflow
you may heard of they opened a private
beta for a quantum computing site now
it's a private beta so you can only join
by invitation if you want to join let me
know I can I can get an invitation to
you and that's well the site is at this
address of course my invitations aren't
but just let me know and well apart from
that I would say it's time to explore
try these tools play around with them
read the tutorials there's much much
more than I got to cover today in the
information material provided by for
example IBM and Microsoft and of course
other sources play around with it and
hopefully we'll get some really cool
results and now ask your questions that
adds two numbers that's a good question
if you want to add two numbers well in
theory a very simple adder would be just
the C not if you have zero and zero you
get zero if you have zero and one you
have one if you have one and zero you
have 1 here 1 1 you get 0 because of
overflow but you always have the problem
of measurement error here you probably
don't want to build something like an
adder in a quantum computer the profile
of quantum computing applications for
one as I said earlier is anything that's
nowadays ought many things at least that
nowadays
you would improve with heuristics so
you'll probably be able to improve those
with quantum computers among these
things are well prime factor prime
factoring of course you can you can do
that nowadays you would basically have
to try all possible combinations and you
can improve that with heuristics but
it's it's difficult another issue that
can be solved with quantum computers is
unstructured search there's an algorithm
called Grover's algorithm where
basically if you have a data set and you
know nothing about how it may or may not
be sorted with any regular binary
computer which you would have to look at
each separate entry and check is that
the one I'm looking for is that the one
I'm looking for is that the one I'm
looking for if you have n entries you'd
need potentially n tries it's certainly
an O of N
Grover's algorithm can do it in oh of
square root of n basically by using this
this state of superposition and looking
at several values at the same time so
anything that goes into the area of
breadth search is a potential candidate
as well and there are probably many many
other problems you can look at that's so
simply nobody has really looked into yet
I'm pretty convinced that it's possible
to write a proper sorting algorithm with
a quantum computer I haven't seen anyone
do it yet and I haven't been able to
come up with one myself but I do think
it's possible we just have to find the
proper algorithm okay
okay so basically the question is can
quantum computers help with floating
points decimal representation infinite
floating points the answer is I don't
know maybe there's a way I haven't seen
anything about that so far in theory I
would say it is possible because you
could choose some kind of representation
within the Blas fear where each points
on the sphere is a possible value and
that in theory at least would be
infinitely many values measuring those
is a bit more difficult because you get
either 0 or 1 so I can't think of a way
to represent infinitely long binary
number floating point numbers off the
top of my head but that doesn't mean
there isn't a way to do it yeah ok so
basically how do you represent numbers
at all in a quantum computer basically
the same way at least you can do it the
same way you do with a binary computer
because when you measure your values
they will be 0 or 1 you don't get a
value on the sphere you get 0
or ones with certain probabilities there
may be better ways of representing
numbers in quantum computers again I
don't know it's something you can
certainly look into there probably is a
better way to do it but we're in the
early stages where that kind of question
is still something
that's as far as I'm aware hasn't been
fully answered so you can go with a
basic representation where zeros and
ones give you your result just like with
a binary representation on a binary
computer and anything from there onwards
is up to research yeah okay
so how do qubits work on a technical
level I'm no expert in this field
basically I can tell you that there are
at least I don't know four or five
different ways in which people have
started building qubits the
superconducting method that is used by
IBM and Google and quite a few other
hardware manufacturers is currently the
most successful method how exactly that
works I'd have to check myself there are
some other ways that don't necessarily
require supercooling and those could be
very promising in the long run because
basically if you want to have a quantum
computer with you if you want to have it
your laptop in your car in your phone
you don't want to have you know a huge
cryostats that you have to carry with
you you don't want to have to call it to
as close to absolute zero as you can get
currently to my understanding at least
those technologies aren't as as advanced
as the superconducting methods and so
we'll have to see
where those go does that answer your
question
great any other questions
yeah sure sure
with Microsoft yes with IBM you can run
it on a simulator basically you have two
options when you have your code in the
quantum experience you can choose the
simulate button and then it will run
automatically it will run immediately on
a simulator and you'll get back your
result in no time you can say run it on
the real quantum computer and they have
a scheduling system I'm not going to get
into it it's easily explained and then
they do send your code to the actual
quantum computer they have in their
facilities will run it your code there
and after a while you get back your
result and this is actual quantum
quantum computing happening that's what
we saw when I showed you the results
where we had all those errors if you run
it on the simulator you get much nicer
results which is great for testing but
of course if you want a realistic image
you should run it on the real device
okay anyone else yeah
can a quantum computer generate truly
random numbers my guess is yes it can
I'm no expert in randomness I must admit
so you would have to ask someone who's
more familiar with what constitutes to
randomness but to my understanding yes
it can
okay anything else that case thank you
for listening and no cats were harmed in
the making of this presentation
[Applause]
[Music]